ils sont désormais trois cent cinq
collégiens il-62 enseignants à posséder
une tablette numérique les claude méric
en direction des collèges a été présenté
ce jeudi 1er décembre au salon régional
de la jeunesse
il ya une feuille d'avis colère
elle vous
deux collèges pour qu elle
enfin le cartable numérique a réuni dans
avec des maîtres mais numérique sur
tablette tenez vous bien du kg 500
grammes seulement
donc ça va vraiment changer la vie de
nos écoliers d'un policier pour ce poids
pour lui qu'a fait un cartable numérique
d'abord grâce à la tablette numérique un
cartables moins lourds et un
environnement numérique qui permet
d'avoir des outils pédagogiques pour
travailler à distance même si les
manuels scolaires reste incontournable
grâce à la tablette plusieurs options
viendront compléter l'apprentissage des
collégiens avec des textes des vidéos
des séquences de cours pour les
enseignants et des suivi individualisé
des nôtres par le suivi la maison
l'établissement scolaire l'école et la
maison c'est qu'au fond rendre la vie
pas seulement départ mais aussi à des
collégiens plus simple plus facile vous
connecter dans la réalité
on n'échappera pas
ce numérique et deux à l'avant et
robiza et de regarder une convention a
été signée entre les départements et le
rectorat pour renforcer ce partenariat
pour atteindre ainsi les objectifs de la
démocratisation du numérique en
direction des plus jeunes le conseil
départemental qui à travers son plan
numérique dote déjà les collèges de
câblage d'accès internet haut débit et
le très haut débit pour un montant
avoisinant les deux millions trois cent
cinquante mille euros nous avons repris
2011 d'accord au conseil départemental
table et la plus grande région et de
collèges classiques de secours aussi sur
la région
ça fait deux
en dix ans depuis 2000 12,61 collège ont
été connectés pour l'année scolaire 2016
une vingtaine de collèges bénéficieront
du plan numérique avec un investissement
de la collectivité de 448 1180 euros